from a world ending apocalypse to yet
more timeline jumps and shenanigans the
third season of the umbrella academy
ends on a huge cliffhanger and a big
reveal about reginald hargreaves yipikai
movie lovers i'm jan and in this video
i'm explaining everything you need to
know about the ending of season three
what the deal was that alison made and
why we're likely getting doppelgangers
in season four spoilers ahead of course
so take care
when the umbrella academy arrived back
in 2019 to find themselves replaced by
the sparrows on the same day they
arrived a kugelblitz a type of black
hole appeared in the basement of the
sparrow academy you see when they
traveled back to the 60s they
inadvertently transferred powers to
young harlem who as he grew up found
himself connected to other powered
people when his mother [ __ ] died on the
1st of october 1989 it was the same day
the umbrella academy's mothers were due
to give birth as the super babies grew
inside them harlan sensed their pain and
when this combined with his grief over
sissy's death he accidentally killed
them preventing the umbrella academy
team from ever being born so when the
gang arrive in this new timeline they
shouldn't actually exist and this
creates a version of the grandfather
paradox a paradox you mean one of those
things that can destroy the universe the
threat the kugelblitz poses to the
entire cosmos now explains why the
commission was so alarmed when they
found out about harlan's powers in the
second season i've never seen anything
like this the anomaly is off the charts
the kugelblitz is unstoppable without
going back in time to prevent their
mothers being killed which is impossible
as the only two commission briefcases
are broken the only remedy lies in the
hotel oblivion the oblivion is located
in an alternate dimension and not to
have the hotel in the comics exist in a
pocket dimension and was used by
hargreaves as a prison for villains and
the numerous cockroaches that keep
popping up are a reference to how the
critters were served to the prisoners at
the hotel in the comics in the tv show
the oblivion contains a machine that can
rebuild the universe should it ever be
destroyed the machine is activated by
the seven bells which it turns out are
seven of the surviving team and when
they stand on the stars on the floor of
the hotel's lobby they create the sigil
which unlocks the machine the oblivion
then reveals that it's basically an
illusion for a matrix-like machine that
controls the reality of the world
another cool detail here is the hotel
floor tiling that creates an optical
illusion another pointer to the hotel
oblivion's perception and reality
altering powers the machine then begins
to pull sparks of light out of the seven
members of the team some think that
allison protests as it appears to be
about to kill them the particles inside
their bodies are the only things that
fuel the machine now these flecks of
light are the ones that hargreaves
released a long time ago back on his
home world and the opening scene of
season three confirmed that they are
indeed the thing that miraculously
impregnated numerous women around the
world who on the same day all gave birth
to super-powered children and this makes
me think it was part of hargreaves plan
to use humans as vessels for
transferring the magical lights from his
homeworld eventually all the way to the
hotel oblivion where he could then
extract them to power up the engine that
would recreate the cosmos with access to
the machine i think then he programmed
the rebirth of the universe in a way
that would prevent the apocalypse on his
home planet and the death of his wife
after all remember what he said i've
seen worlds end in ways that would knock
your socks off but you'll never forget
your first your home your original sin
you never stop wondering did i do enough
to save the people i loved did you no
but i was hoping you children could help
me out with that season three also
revealed that bringing his wife back to
life has been a huge driving force for
hargreaves when we discovered that he
was keeping her body cryogenically
frozen in a container on the moon he
even sent luther there for four years on
an unexplained mission to keep her safe
you wasted my life on the moon and for
what i left you to god the most precious
thing in the universe i even suspect
that hargreaves himself may have cycled
through various loops in time in order
to figure out what combination of events
would eventually lead him to discover
the key to fixing the universe in his
favor in season one's flashback to
hargreaves arrival in america we can see
from the immigration stamp that this was
1928
but in season three we discover
hargreaves was already on earth in 1918
looking for the portal to the alternate
dimension even after uncovering the
portal his attempts to get safe access
inside were thwarted by the guardians
protecting the other side and when he
saw how a group of trained soldiers were
so easily defeated by the samurai
warriors that might have led him to the
idea that he needed a group of
extraordinary super-powered individuals
for the task for that he might have gone
back again in time to release the
magical lights and since then he's gone
through many cycles of different super
babies and children until finding the
seven who would become the seven bells
another big clue to hargreaves secret
time travel shenanigans is the fact
there's a televator sign hidden in the
basement of the sparrow academy in the
comics the televator is a contraption
that can travel across space time and
dimensions and in the season 260s
timeline we saw that hargreaves had
blueprints in his office for building a
televator as he said to 5 he's witnessed
numerous apocalypses before so perhaps
that's how he's escaped through time and
space on several occasions and if you
like this theory or this video so far
hit that like button i really appreciate
it but what was the deal that alison
made with reginald on the night of
luther and sloane's wedding i think she
offered to unite her side of the family
by reconciling with them the following
day then trying to convince them to join
hargreaves mission to the oblivion
although that didn't exactly work she
had tried and so once on the other side
in return perhaps out of some slight
empathy for her given his mission was
also to recover his lost love hargreaves
programmed the new universe so that she
could have the two cherished things
she'd lost in all the timeline changes
her daughter claire from 2019 and her
husband ray from the sixties i'm almost
done and when i am you and i will get
what we came here for this new universe
is alison's idealized world where her
mistakes and problems from the previous
two seasons are now gone in season one
after allison's husband patrick found
her using her powers on their daughter
he divorced her and took custody of
claire and in season two she had to
leave her husband rey who she'd fallen
in love with so that she could travel
back to the future now in this new and
improved timeline allison has managed to
get the two people she loves from
different times in one place reginald
too got what he was finally after and
created a world where not only is his
wife abigail still alive but once more
he's a billionaire with what looks like
an even bigger business empire this time
as for alice and siblings they emerge
and the new world dramatically changed
luther has lost his simian body diego's
fingers that was sliced off by one of
the guardians have returned and five
also has both his arms the wrinkle
however is that they don't have their
powers anymore i can't blink now it's
possible that they lost their abilities
when the particles were extracted out of
them by the oblivion's world reset
machine which would also mean that
allison would still have her powers but
it doesn't totally explain how luther is
100 human again or how diego's fingers
and five's arm have returned and thanks
to this cryptic final scene where we see
ben riding the subway to a stop in the
financial district of seoul korea i
think that in season 4 we'll be seeing
doppelgangers the clues are subtle but
notice how this ben doesn't have a scar
on his face implying that it isn't
sparrow ben plus his hair style is
different the scene is also a callback
to the opening scene of season 3 where a
young korean girl on the subway is
impregnated by the magical lights and
gives birth immediately whether ben was
born that way in this new timeline we
don't yet know and therefore we can't be
sure whether this ben has any powers
after all hargreaves may well have
decided that he didn't need to release
any magic lights this time after the
adjustments he'd made to the timeline
with the machine at the oblivion i think
this final scene is also pointing to the
idea that in season 4 we'll be getting
doppelgangers for the other umbrella
academy members as well remember how at
the start of season 3 there was specific
mention by 5 of how they could expect to
meet a copy of themselves in the new
timeline dad didn't adopt us as babies
but those babies still existed here odds
are we each have identical versions of
ourselves our doppelgangers probably
aren't even in the same time zone as us
that never happened in season three
because the umbrella's mothers all died
before they gave birth but i think the
point of five bringing up the subject
was to set up the idea for season four
in other words it's basically chekhov's
doppelgangers if the umbrella gang's
powers do return and the doppels also
have powers it could be fun if they get
into an argument or fight with
themselves much like five did in season
two another theory i have about how the
team might regain their powers is with
the help of a televator as i mentioned
earlier this machine can not only travel
through time and space but also between
dimensions meaning that they could try
and return to their old universe before
it was kugelblitz to get back their old
powers and then stop the apocalypse a
hint at this idea might be the fact that
they came into this new universe via the
door of an elevator from the hotel
oblivion so could that elevator itself
be a secret televator with a hidden
activation switch also to be revealed in
season four is why sloane is missing in
the final scene given she was with the
others at the moment that alison pressed
the button i don't think she's been
written out of the show especially given
that luther has run off looking for her
and i suspect the opening scene of her
reading a travel book with the leaning
tower of pisa on the cover is a hint
that she's ended up somewhere else
perhaps italy and we know when she was
with luther she talked about wanting to
get away i know there are better places
out there in the world one day i want to
see them all i'm also curious to see
what happens with lila and diego
especially as she's pregnant and whether
they'll end up having a super baby
another question is how is luther back
at all given he died did the ghostly
spirit of him that klaus conjured up at
the oblivion mean he could be reborn
into the new world klaus chases after
lutheran so there's something between
the two of them that will be explained
in season four in fact there were some
neat clues very early on that predicted
how both klaus and luther would end up
together in the afterlife something i
explain in my season 3 easter eggs and
things you missed video which i'll be
uploading next i'll add a link here and
in the description as soon as it's ready
so movie lovers what do you think about
the third season of the umbrella academy
and do you have any theories about what
will happen next comment with your
thoughts below next tap here to discover
all the incredible easter eggs and
little details hidden in season three
and if you liked this video do leave a
thumbs up thanks for enjoying the
umbrella academy with me and hope you
have a marvellous movie loving week
yapikai movie lovers